It took not one, not two, but three, three big breaks to get Marisela and Yadira to college. Every time they got a break, they thought it was a done deal, nothing more to say, and then they just had to start over from scratch and wait for the next bolt of lightning. They were honors students, in the top 10% of their class, AP courses, all that stuff. They were ambitious. They wanted to go to college. But they didn't have the money for it.
为了让Marisela和Yadira上大学，她们经历了不仅仅是一次、两次，而是三次重大转机。每一次她们以为有了转机，事情就定下来了，再无悬念，结果却总是不得不从头开始，等待下一道闪电。她们是荣誉学生，成绩排在年级前10%，修过大学先修课程（AP），样样精通。她们很有抱负，想上大学，但却拿不出学费。
Then one day, in their junior year, a man comes to their high school talking about a scholarship program called the Daniels Fund, which sends students to special college prep classes for months. And then if they do well in those classes, they get their entire tuition paid at the college of their choice. Great, right? It's a first big break.
后来有一天，在高三那年，一个人来到她们高中，介绍一个叫“丹尼尔基金会”（Daniels Fund）的奖学金项目，该项目会资助学生参加为期几个月的大学预科班。如果他们在这些课程中表现出色，就能获得所选大学的全额学费资助。听起来很棒，对吧？这是第一个大转机。
They get in the program. They start the special classes. They're happy. They're doing great. And then they hear a rumor that despite what they had been told by that man who came to visit their class, the scholarships only go to US citizens. Marisela and Yadira-- they live in the US, but they are not citizens. Their parents brought them to the US from Mexico when they were little kids. So they went to their adviser. And they were told, yeah, there was a misunderstanding. They weren't going to be able to get any scholarship money when these special classes were finished.
她们进入了这个项目，开始了预科班学习。她们很开心，表现也很棒。但随后她们听到一个传言：尽管之前来班里访问的那个人那么说，但奖学金只发给美国公民。Marisela和Yadira虽然住在美国，但她们不是公民。她们小时候被父母从墨西哥带到美国。于是她们去找指导老师。老师告诉她们，确实是个误会，预科班结束后，她们无法获得任何奖学金。
And I remember she said that they didn't want us in the prep program because we were taking up the space of the students that could actually get it. That's when it really hit me. Like woah. And I remember getting very depressed and I even started skipping some classes. Because I remember thinking that why do so much work for nothing? So that's where I would just go into my room and just stay there the whole day. I would talk on the phone. And then when there was no one to talk to, I would just sit there and think.
我记得她说，他们不希望我们参加预科班，因为我们占用了那些真正能拿到奖学金的学生的资源。那一刻我真的被击中了。就像是……哇。我记得当时非常沮丧，甚至开始逃课。因为我记得我在想，为什么要为这些没用的事情做那么多努力？所以我就躲进房间，一整天待在那里。我会打电话，没人说话的时候，我就坐在那儿胡思乱想。
Here's how harsh this was. Marisela and Yadira had two friends in advanced placement classes whose families also came over from Mexico. Except the friends were born in the United States. They could get the scholarships. They had social security numbers, which you need before you can get most financial aid. And suddenly, it felt kind of hard to be friends with them.
情况有多残酷呢？Marisela和Yadira在大学先修班有两个朋友，她们的家庭也是从墨西哥过来的。不同的是，这两个朋友出生在美国。她们能拿到奖学金，她们有社会安全号码，而那是获得大多数经济援助的前提。突然之间，感觉和她们交朋友变得有点困难了。
We were all the same, and we all had the same type of parents and the same type of living. And it was just like-- I was mad that they had their papers and that we didn't when, in fact, we were the same. It was just like luck or something, that they got more lucky than we did. And it was just not fair because it's not like you could-- we couldn't buy luck. We could buy a fake social security, but we can't buy the luck to get a real one.
我们都一样，父母类型相同，生活方式也相同。我就觉得……我很生气，因为她们有身份文件而我们没有，事实上我们是一样的。这就像是运气之类的事情，她们比我们更幸运。这太不公平了，因为这不是你能……我们买不来运气。我们可以买到伪造的社会安全号码，但我们买不到获得真实号码的运气。
And then, Marisela and Yadira got their second big break. They found a scholarship program that helps undocumented students. But again, there was a catch. Yadira got a full scholarship. Marisela, she didn't. They both cried when they got the news.
后来，Marisela和Yadira迎来了第二次大转机。她们找到了一个资助无证学生的奖学金项目。但还是有附加条件。Yadira拿到了全额奖学金，而Marisela没有。得到消息时，她们都哭了。
And that whole day it was really hard for us to talk to each other.
那整整一天，我们之间很难交流。
This is Marisela.
这是Marisela。
Not because-- I wasn't mad at her. But just because everything came tumbling on me. Oh, I felt like less, like less than her. I saw my life in an instant, what it was going to be like. And I saw bad things coming, like me working, something that I don't want to do, or marrying young just to get out of a situation.
不是因为……我并没有生她的气。只是因为所有压力都朝我涌来。哦，我觉得自己低人一等，不如她。我瞬间看到了我的生活，未来会是什么样子。我预感到糟糕的事情要发生，比如我得去打工，做我不愿意做的事，或者为了摆脱困境而早早结婚。
Later that day, Marisela told her mom.
那天晚些时候，Marisela告诉了她妈妈。
I cried so hard. And she didn't know what to do. She was like, oh, don't worry. She started crying too. She was all like, I'll raise enough money, you could go to beauty school, like to do your hair and to do your nails. You could go there. I'm like, oh mom. I didn't know what to tell her, because for her it was a big thing. But to me, that's not what I wanted.
我哭得很厉害。她不知道该怎么办。她说，哦，别担心。她也开始哭。她说，我会攒够钱，你可以去学美容，去给人家做头发和指甲。你可以去那里。我说，哦妈妈。我不知道该说什么，因为对她来说这已经很不容易了。但对我来说，那不是我想要的。
This happens more often than you'd think. Public schools in America have to accept undocumented kids up through high school. But once they graduate-- this is over 50,000 kids a year-- they have no more rights. They can't work because they're not citizens. And though, theoretically, they can go to college as international students from another country, in practice, most undocumented kids are like other kids. They need financial aid, which is a problem because most scholarships follow what the federal government does. And federal student aid, Pell Grants, can't go to undocumented students.
这种情况比你想象的更常见。美国的公立学校必须接收无证儿童直到高中毕业。但一旦他们毕业——每年有超过5万名这样的孩子——他们就失去了任何权利。他们不能工作，因为他们不是公民。尽管从理论上讲，他们可以作为外国学生上大学，但在实践中，大多数无证学生和其他孩子一样。他们需要经济援助，而这又是个问题，因为大多数奖学金都遵循联邦政府的政策。而联邦学生援助（佩尔助学金）不能发给无证学生。
Given all that, it was especially amazing that Marisela got her third big break. A private donor heard of her situation and ponied up most of the money that she would need for college. The school put up the rest. At first, Marisela thought, OK, three big breaks-- three huge big breaks-- now they're set. They are set. But actually, as time has passed, other problems have become clearer to them. For instance, it's a long shot that they're ever going to become citizens. Even if they marry Americans, it would take years to make that happen legally. And in the meantime, they're scared of getting caught by the INS. They worry about the future as much as they ever did.
鉴于这一切，Marisela能获得第三次大转机实在令人惊叹。一位私人捐赠者听说了她的情况，资助了她上大学所需的大部分费用，学校承担了其余部分。起初，Marisela想，好吧，三次大转机——三次巨大的转机——现在她们稳定了，一切都搞定了。但随着时间的推移，其他问题对她们来说变得越来越明显。例如，她们获得公民身份的可能性微乎其微。即使她们嫁给美国人，在法律上也要花费数年时间。与此同时，她们害怕被移民局抓到。她们对未来的担忧和以往一样多。
I'm working really hard in college. But I still don't know what's waiting for me. It seems like I'm just living life to the day. I have goals. But I don't have ways of how I'm going to get there.
我在大学里非常努力。但我依然不知道未来在等待着我什么。感觉我只是在过一天算一天。我有目标，但我不知道该如何实现。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, My Big Break, stories of people who get their shot, their chance, their once in a lifetime opportunity that they think can solve all their problems, and then, of course, after the big break they discover all sorts of other problems that they never imagined before. Act One of our program today, Take My Break, Please. In that act, two entertainers get the biggest possible chance anybody ever could to make the big time, and they blow it. Act Two, What Happens in Baghdad Stays in Baghdad. Two young men decide that it would be interesting to be part of the rebuilding of Iraq, and so they take a bus to Baghdad during the war and the bombings and the kidnappings and the danger, and they try to make their mark. Act Three, Oedipus Hex, the true story of a third grader who stumbles upon a rare opportunity at making his mother happy, and driving his abusive father out of the picture forever. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，我是Ira Glass，这是由公共广播国际发行的《美国生活》。今天我们的节目主题是“我的大转机”，讲述那些获得机会、得到机遇、拥有一生一次的转机，并以为这些转机能解决所有问题，结果却在转机后发现了种种从未想象过的新麻烦的人们的故事。今天节目的第一幕，“请带走我的转机”。在这一幕中，两位艺人获得了有史以来最大的成名机会，结果他们搞砸了。第二幕，“巴格达发生的，留在巴格达”。两名年轻人认为参与伊拉克重建会很有趣，于是他们在战争、轰炸、绑架和危险之中乘公交车前往巴格达，试图闯出一番事业。第三幕，“俄狄浦斯之咒”，一个三年级学生的真实故事，他意外地获得了让母亲幸福、并永远赶走虐待他的父亲的难得机会。请继续收听。
Act One, Take My Break, Please. Well, we begin our program with a classic big break which results in an equally classic result. David Segal tells the story.
第一幕，“请带走我的转机”。好吧，我们以一个经典的重大转机开始我们的节目，其结果也是同样经典。David Segal讲述这个故事。
Mitzi McCall and Charlie Brill were a sketch comedy act back in the early 1960s, playing small clubs around the country, mostly in Los Angeles where they lived. They were married. They still are actually. And they were struggling. Then one day they got a phone call that changed their lives.
Mitzi McCall和Charlie Brill是20世纪60年代初的一个小品喜剧组合，在全国各地的小俱乐部演出，主要是他们居住的洛杉矶。他们结婚了，事实上现在还是。当时他们正在苦苦挣扎。后来有一天，他们接到一个改变人生的电话。
We were sitting at home, and I don't know what we were--
我们当时坐在家里，我不知道我们在做什么——
Starving.
饿着肚子。
Starving. No, we weren't starving.
饿着肚子。不，我们没饿着肚子。
Yes. I was starving.
是的，我饿着呢。
Well, you were hungry that day.
好吧，你那天是饿了。
Oh, was that it?
哦，是这样吗？
Yeah. And the phone rang and it was our manager, Mace Neufeld, and he said, guess what? What? I got you on The Ed Sullivan Show . And we let out a scream because that was THE show. It's like today, young comics want to get on--
是啊。电话响了，是我们经理Mace Neufeld打来的，他说，猜猜看？什么？我给你们争取到了《埃德·沙利文秀》。我们尖叫了起来，因为那可是“那档”节目。就像今天，年轻喜剧演员想上——
Dave Letterman.
大卫·莱特曼的节目。
Jay Leno, Dave Letterman. Well, this was--
杰·雷诺，大卫·莱特曼。好吧，当时这就是——
The ultimate.
终极目标。
Bigger. If you got a shot on Ed Sullivan , you had a shot at stardom. We were just so thrilled. And immediately, we started to work on the piece of material that we selected for The Ed Sullivan Show . And we rehearsed and rehearsed, and we fine-tuned it. We ran down to The Horn in Santa Monica. We broke it in. It got a lovely, lovely reaction. And we told everybody. In fact, I think I sky-wrote it over Hollywood. We're on The Ed Sullivan Show. Yoo-hoo!
更重要。如果你能在《埃德·沙利文秀》上露脸，你就有了成名的机会。我们太激动了。我们立即开始打磨为《埃德·沙利文秀》选好的节目素材。我们一遍遍排练，精益求精。我们去了圣莫尼卡的The Horn俱乐部试演，反响非常好。我们告诉了所有人。事实上，我想我还在好莱坞上空写过字宣传呢：我们上《埃德·沙利文秀》啦！嘿！
Yeah.
是啊。
And we were on our way.
我们就快出人头地了。
This wasn't just a shot at greatness. This was a chance to meet a few of their idols who'd be on the show that night too, people like Tessie O'Shea, Georgia Brown, who were both big musical theater stars. But to Charlie and Mitzi, the biggest deal of all was a guy they'd already met.
这不仅是走向伟大的机会，还有机会见到当晚也将参加节目的偶像，比如Tessie O'Shea和Georgia Brown，她们都是音乐剧的大明星。但对Charlie和Mitzi来说，最了不起的是他们之前已经见过的一个人。
We were just in awe of Frank Gorshin, a great, great, great impressionist--
我们当时非常敬佩Frank Gorshin，一位伟大的、伟大的、伟大的模仿艺人——
Impressionist.
模仿艺人。
--And The Riddler on Batman.
——也是《蝙蝠侠》里的“谜语人”。
We had probably done maybe something with Frank Gorshin.
我们大概和Frank Gorshin合作过什么吧。
I think it was something for Frank Gorshin. I shined his shoes. And I was so in awe. So, we get to New York and we go to rehearsal by taxi. And there's thousands of people in the streets, clamoring and--
我想是给Frank Gorshin帮忙之类的。我给他擦过鞋。当时我非常崇拜他。所以，我们坐出租车去纽约参加彩排。街上有成千上万的人，大声喧哗——
And the streets are cordoned off. Is that the word?
街道都被警戒线封锁了。是这个词吗？
Yeah. Cordoned. And I looked at Mitzi and I said, my god, all this for Frank Gorshin.
是啊。封锁。我看着Mitzi说，我的天，这些人都是为Frank Gorshin来的。
They were given the worst dressing room in the building, on the top floor, a space they shared with the soda machine. But they didn't care. They were both 26 years old, and they were about to go national. But first, it was time for a dress rehearsal.
他们被安排在大楼顶层最差的化妆间，和一个自动售货机挤在一起。但他们不在乎。他们才26岁，即将走向全国舞台。但首先是带妆彩排。
Here's the deal. We didn't know that the dress rehearsal was something that was looked at very carefully.
事情是这样的，我们当时不知道彩排是非常受关注的。
By all the executives.
所有高管都会来看。
Exactly.
没错。
And they have an audience. We didn't know. We were coming down in our bathrobes with hair curlers. And we go through our act.
而且还有观众。我们不知道。我们穿着浴袍，头上戴着发卷就去了。我们演示了节目。
And when we get to a punchline, instead of doing--
当我们演到包袱点时，我们没有演——
The punchline.
那个包袱。
--We go blah, blah, blah.
——而是说，叭、叭、叭。
Because we don't want to reveal the punchline. We want the band to laugh. And we don't want-- it was a secret, our punchlines. So we used to go-- and here we are. And Mitzi, by the way, blah, blah, blah. So then we schlep upstairs to our dressing room and we hear in the loudspeaker, McCall and Brill, Mr. Sullivan's office please. McCall and Brill. So we go down and we go into Mr. Sullivan's office and there he was--
因为我们不想提前剧透包袱。我们想让现场乐队笑。不想让别人提前知道……那是我们的秘密。所以我们以前就这么演……就这样。Mitzi顺便说一句，叭、叭、叭。然后我们拖着沉重的步伐回到化妆间，听到喇叭里说：McCall和Brill，请到沙利文先生办公室来。McCall和Brill。我们走过去进入沙利文先生的办公室，他在那里——
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
--Ed Sullivan. He was sitting in the chair, getting made up. And I looked at the man who could make our entire careers. So he said, what you did in dress rehearsal-- first of all, I don't get the blah, blah, blahs. Is that-- I'm not getting that. And we said, no, Mr. Sullivan. Those are our punchlines and we want them to be fresh.
——埃德·沙利文。他坐在椅子上化妆。我看着那个能决定我们整个事业前途的人。他说，你们彩排时的表演——首先，我不明白那些“叭、叭、叭”是什么意思。这是……我不懂那个。我们说，不，沙利文先生。那是我们的笑点包袱，我们想让它们在正式演出时保持新鲜感。
And he said, oh, well, I wish you would let us in on them for the dress rehearsal. And he said, and the piece of material you're doing is too sophisticated for this audience. And I went, what? Because I had seen the Sullivan show all my life. And he said, well, there's going to be mostly 14, 15, 16-year-old girls in the audience tonight. And kids. And it never occurred to me to say, why? What are we doing, like a circus show? And he said, so show me your entire act.
他说，哦，但我希望你们在彩排时能让我们看看。他说，你们表演的素材对于这个观众群来说太深奥了。我说，什么？因为我这辈子都在看沙利文秀。他说，好吧，今晚的观众大多是14、15、16岁的女孩。还有小孩子。我当时竟然没问：为什么？我们是在演马戏团吗？他说，现在，把你们所有的节目都演示给我看。
And because we were so new and eager to please, we stood there in the office and showed Mr. Sullivan our entire nightclub act. Anything we had ever worked on.
因为我们很年轻，又急于讨好他，我们就站在办公室里给沙利文先生表演了我们所有的夜店节目。任何我们准备过的东西。
Which was like 25, 30 minutes of--
大概有25、30分钟长——
Sketches.
小品。
Blah, blah, blah.
叭、叭、叭。
Yeah, sketches.
是啊，小品。
And he said, OK, here's the deal. We're going to put that first girl that comes in--
他说，好吧，就这样。我们要把第一个进来的那个女孩——
In the first sketch. We'll put her in the second sketch. But then you do the other girl that you did in the third sketch in the second sketch.
放到第一个小品里。我们把她放到第二个小品里。但是你们把你们在第三个小品里做的那个女孩表演放到第二个小品里。
And then that's what you end with.
然后那是你们结尾的节目。
That's what you end with. Now we went, uh, OK.
那就是你们结尾的节目。我们当时想，呃，好吧。
They went back upstairs in something close to a panic. Basically, they had just been told to write a new act, right then and there, instead of the routine they had been fine-tuning for weeks. They might have freaked out, but they didn't have time. The curtain was going up in an hour.
他们惊慌失措地回到楼上。基本上，他们刚刚被要求当场写一个新的剧目，而不是他们已经反复打磨了几周的那些段子。他们本可以崩溃的，但没时间了。演出一个小时后就要开始了。
We were in a daze. We didn't really know what he said. Should we put the first--
我们当时都懵了。我们其实没听懂他说了什么。我们应该把第一个——
What did he say?
他说了什么？
If we take the first girl and put it in the third-- and then there was a knock on the door. The door was open, but there was a knock. And there's this guy standing there with funny hair and granny glasses. And he said--
如果把第一个女孩放到第三个小品里——然后有人敲门。门是开着的，但有人敲门。有个家伙站在那儿，留着滑稽的发型，戴着老奶奶式的眼镜。他说——
Give us a coke-luv.
给我们要个可乐，爱人。
Give us a coke-luv. And I looked at Mitzi and I said, this guy wants a glove or something. I'm not sure what he wants. And he started to laugh and he said, no, give us a coke-luv.
给我们要个可乐，爱人。我看着Mitzi说，这家伙是要手套还是什么的。我不确定他想要什么。他开始笑，他说，不，给我们个可乐。
And he pointed to the machine.
他指着那台机器。
The Coke machine. And I said, oh yeah, well come in. It's all yours. And he said, can you give me a dime? 10 cents. And I said, oh, I got to buy you the Coke as well? OK.
那台可乐机。我说，哦好的，进来吧，全是你们的。他说，能给我一角钱吗？10美分。我说，哦，还要我给你们买可乐？好吧。
What do you think, we're made out of money, kid?
你以为我们是印钞票的吗，小伙子？
Yeah.
是啊。
The worst part was that this guy seemed to want to just hang out. So he helped himself to a seat on the sofa.
最糟糕的是，这家伙看起来只想在这儿待着。于是他自顾自地坐在沙发上。
While he's talking to us, he takes out of his pocket a napkin and a pen and he's drawing me. He's looking at me and he's drawing me. That's nice. And he did some pictures of me and Mitzi on napkins.
当他和我们说话时，他从口袋里掏出一张餐巾纸和一支笔，他在画我。他看着我，正在画我。那挺好的。他在餐巾纸上画了一些我和Mitzi的画像。
All we thought about was, I wish this kid would go so we could work on our act. Get out of here.
我们满脑子想的都是，我真希望这小子赶紧走，这样我们好排练节目。赶紧走吧。
We haven't put the first character in the third sketch and the second in the-- and he left. And we looked at each other and said, OK, now. What are we doing? McCall and Brill, McCall and Brill, onstage for the show.
我们还没把第一个角色放进第三个小品，把第二个放进——然后他走了。我们互相对视，说，好了，现在怎么办？McCall和Brill，McCall和Brill，准备上台表演。
Good evening, ladies and gentlemen. Tonight, live from New York, The Ed Sullivan Show.
女士们、先生们，晚上好。今晚，纽约现场直播，《埃德·沙利文秀》。
The show was about to begin. All the performers gathered in the wings, waiting for their turn. Finally, Ed Sullivan came out and announced the first act.
演出就要开始了。所有的表演者都在侧幕等待。最后，埃德·沙利文出来宣布第一个节目。
Ladies and gentlemen, The Beatles.
女士们、先生们，披头士乐队。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
We were on The Ed Sullivan Show with The Beatles.
我们和披头士乐队一起上了《埃德·沙利文秀》。
[MUSIC-"ALL MY LOVING" BY THE BEATLES]
[音乐：披头士的《All My Loving》]
We didn't realize that's what the crowds were for. Because, to be very honest, we didn't really know who The Beatles were.
我们当时没意识到那是为了谁尖叫。因为老实说，我们真的不知道披头士乐队是谁。
Actually, our manager, when he called us and said, you're going to be on The Ed Sullivan Show. And he said, and guess what? You're going to be with The Beatles. And we said, who?
其实，我们的经理打电话给我们说，你们要上《埃德·沙利文秀》了。他说，猜猜看？你们要和披头士乐队一起上。我们问，谁？
The guy with the pen? The one who drew the pictures? That, of course, was John Lennon. And this was February 9, 1964, the first time a US audience had laid eyes on The Beatles. Years later, Lennon said he thought the kids that night had lost their minds. Charlie, watching from 20 feet away, thought so too.
那个拿笔的家伙？画画的那个人？那当然是约翰·列侬。那是1964年2月9日，美国观众第一次见到披头士。多年后，列侬说他当时觉得那天晚上的孩子们都疯了。Charlie在20英尺外看着，也觉得如此。
Honest to God, my hand to God, I tell you-- we couldn't hear them. The screams, all through what they did, were so loud I never got a chance to hear what they sounded like, who was singing.
对着上帝发誓，我告诉你——我们根本听不见他们唱歌。尖叫声贯穿了他们的整个演出，声音太大了，我根本没机会听出他们听起来什么样，谁在唱歌。
This was something different.
这完全不同。
Yeah, I'd heard about Sinatra at the Paramount. People were screaming. But this, I never heard or saw such bedlam in my life. Now, when they're finished, the screams keep going on.
是啊，我听说过辛纳屈在派拉蒙剧院演出时，人们都在尖叫。但这……我这辈子从没听过、也没见过这样的混乱。现在，当他们唱完时，尖叫声还在继续。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
It must have dawned on you at that moment, or was it before, that this was a cultural phenomenon? Just off the charts.
那一刻你肯定意识到，或者之前就意识到了，这是一种文化现象？完全超出了图表水平。
I really need to be rigorously honest right now. No, it didn't, no.
我现在真的需要极其诚实地说。没有，真的没有。
Well, think about it. Think it over.
好吧，再想想看。
All right I'll think it over. No.
好吧，我会想一下。没有。
OK.
好的。
It never occurred.
从来没想过。
No. We were too nervous of what we were going to do.
没有。我们太紧张我们要做的表演了。
Please.
拜托。
I mean, I knew they were a hit.
我是说，我知道他们很火。
But, you know what? We hadn't gone on yet. I wanted to know that we were going to be fabulous.
但是你知道吗？我们还没上台呢。我想确保我们的表演很精彩。
Our careers were at stake here.
我们的职业生涯危在旦夕。
Crazy.
太疯狂了。
73 million Americans watched The Ed Sullivan Show that night, about 40% of the entire country. Ordinarily, when that many people come together, it's for the last episode of a long-running TV series or for playoff games, teams they already know. Not for a show that turns the stage over to an act that nobody's heard of. Arguably, Mitzi and Charlie had the single greatest break in the history of show business.
当晚有7300万美国人观看了《埃德·沙利文秀》，约占全国总人口的40%。通常情况下，当这么多人聚在一起时，是为了看一部长寿电视剧的大结局，或者是为了看他们已经熟悉的季后赛队伍。而不是为了看一个把舞台让给没人听说过的组合的节目。可以说，Mitzi和Charlie经历了演艺史上最伟大的转机。
People forget this was an hour long program, with The Beatles playing a few songs at the beginning and then a few songs toward the end. In between, there were six different acts from Vaudeville, from Broadway, from the circus, from everything rock was about to bulldoze aside. It was basically the future sharing a bill with the doomed. Which is why, after The Beatles finished singing "She Loves You," the next thing on The Ed Sullivan Show that night was a guy in a tux doing a card trick.
人们忘了这是一个一小时长的节目，披头士在开头唱了几首歌，结尾又唱了几首。中间有六个不同的节目，有杂耍、有百老汇表演、有马戏、有摇滚乐即将扫荡的一切。基本上是未来与被淘汰的过去在同一个节目里。这就是为什么在披头士唱完《She Loves You》之后，当晚《埃德·沙利文秀》的下一个节目是一个穿着礼服表演扑克牌魔术的家伙。
We do the trick with one, two, three, four, red spot cards. Now from these four red spot cards I take in my right hand-- my right hand is, of course, always the hand with the thumb on the left side. Now in this hand--
我们表演扑克魔术，一、二、三、四，四张红点牌。现在从这四张红点牌里，我用右手拿走——我的右手，当然永远是拇指在左边的那只手。现在在这只手里——
There is an acrobatic novelty act. There's Tessie O'Shea, a very large woman in a sequined gown, playing a banjo, doing her signature tune, "Two Ton Tessie from Tennessee."
接着是一个杂技节目。还有Tessie O'Shea，一个身穿亮片礼服的魁梧女性，弹着班卓琴，表演她的成名曲《来自田纳西的重两吨的Tessie》。
[SINGING] They play tennis on her double chin. They call her Two Ton Tessie, Two Ton Tessie from Nashville, Tennessee.
[演唱] 她们在她的双下巴上打网球。她们叫她重两吨的Tessie，重两吨的Tessie，来自田纳西州纳什维尔。
Frank Gorshin comes on with 10 minutes of impersonations-- Dean Martin, Burt Lancaster, Anthony Quinn. The far-fetched conceit of his act doesn't seem quite so far-fetched 40 years later.
Frank Gorshin上场进行了10分钟的模仿表演——迪恩·马丁、伯特·兰卡斯特、安东尼·奎因。40年后回看，他那种荒诞的构思似乎并没有那么荒诞。
Well, it's election year and once again a lot of the Hollywood stars will be out campaigning for the candidates of both parties. Well, a funny thing occurred to me, what if these stars should suddenly decide to run for these offices themselves? They'd have no trouble getting votes because of their popularity. In just a short time, the stars will be running the country.
好吧，又是选举年，好莱坞明星们又会出来为两党的候选人助选。好吧，我想到一件有趣的事，如果这些明星突然决定亲自参选这些职位会怎样？因为他们的知名度，他们根本不需要担心选票。很快，明星们就会统治这个国家。
He imagines a meeting of the US Senate where character actor, Broderick Crawford is Vice President and people like Marlon Brando are senators.
他构想了一场美国参议院会议，角色演员Broderick Crawford担任副总统，像马龙·白兰度这样的人担任参议员。
Tonight, we're going to discuss what an [UNINTELLIGIBLE] change made the present two-party system [UNINTELLIGIBLE] would you raise your hand and say, aye? Opposed, no. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] 10-4.
今晚，我们要讨论一下[听不清]变动对现行两党体制的影响[听不清]，请举手说“同意”？反对的，说“不”。[听不清] 10-4。
Mr. Chairman, for years now, year after year after year, there have been just two major parties-- one at Frank Sinatra's house and the other one at Dean Martin's.
主席先生，多年来，年复一年，一直只有两个主要党派——一个在弗兰克·辛纳屈家，另一个在迪恩·马丁家。
Just two years after this, Ronald Reagan was elected Governor of California.
两年后，罗纳德·里根当选为加利福尼亚州州长。
[MUSIC- "THE ARTFUL DODGER" BY DAVY JONES]
[音乐：Davy Jones演唱的《The Artful Dodger》]
This is the Artful Dodger from the musical, Oliver , played here by an 18-year-old Davy Jones. When he heard the screams that evening, he thought-- and this is a quote-- "I'd like a little bit of this action." Two years later, he was cast as a member of The Monkeys, the made-for-TV knockoff of The Beatles.
这是音乐剧《奥利弗》中的“机灵鬼”，由18岁的Davy Jones扮演。当他那天晚上听到尖叫声时，他想——引用他的话——“我也想要点这种反响。”两年后，他被选为Monkees乐队成员，那是披头士乐队的一个模仿版电视组合。
Mitzi and Charlie were slated for what was probably the worst slot on the show. They were the last act before The Beatles returned for the final songs.
Mitzi和Charlie被安排在节目中最差的时段，大概是披头士回来唱最后一首歌之前的最后一个节目。
We were in a daze. But we heard him introduce us. We walked out. Now, the screams came on because they wanted The Beatles.
我们当时都懵了。但我们听见他介绍了我们。我们走上台。现在，尖叫声响起来了，因为他们想要的是披头士。
That's when I said I thought I heard, get them off.
就在那时，我说我好像听到了“让他们滚下去”。
Yes.
是的。
Did you hear that?
你听到了吗？
I think I said it.
我想是我说的。
Now, we take you to Hollywood at a very tense moment in the career of a young, aspiring actress, the office of McCall and Brill.
现在，我们要把镜头转向好莱坞，一位年轻、有抱负的女演员职业生涯中非常紧张的时刻——McCall和Brill的办公室。
Miss Tidy, would you come into my office right away please?
Tidy小姐，你能马上到我办公室来吗，拜托？
Yes, sir. Neat, neat, neat, neat, everything nice and neat. That's me. Hello, sir.
好的，长官。整洁，整洁，整洁，整洁，所有事情都要整洁。那是我。你好，长官。
Miss Tidy, I am having a terrible time trying to find a young actress to star in my next motion picture.
Tidy小姐，我正为找不到一位年轻女演员来主演我的下一部电影而焦头烂额。
Yes sir.
是的，长官。
Now, are the young ladies outside waiting to be interviewed?
现在，外面的年轻女士们在等候面试吗？
Yes sir, they're neatly waiting outside sir. I'll send them in.
是的，长官，她们在外面整齐地等待着。我这就让她们进来。
Just one at a time, Miss Tidy.
一次进来一个，Tidy小姐。
The premise here is that Charlie's a director casting a movie, and Mitzi is his secretary and then a bunch of different women auditioning for the role. She plays an aspiring starlet.
这里的设定是Charlie是一名选角导演，Mitzi是他的秘书，然后是一群不同女性来试镜。她饰演一个渴望成名的明星小苗。
Hi, sir. You might not remember me, but I was Miss Palm Springs back in 1956.
嗨，长官。你可能不记得我了，但我是1956年的棕榈泉小姐。
A stage mom.
一个狂热的星妈。
So if you're not interested in her, maybe you can be interested in me.
所以如果你对她没兴趣，也许你可以对我感兴趣。
Well, I'm really not interested.
好吧，我真的没兴趣。
You know, I have a little talent. [SINGING] 'Cause everything's coming up roses.
你知道，我有一点天赋。[演唱] 因为一切正在好转……
And a method actor.
还有一个方法派演员。
Then and only then can the true justification of the motivation of our inside urgency, henceforth find the infinitesimal need of our outward action, dig?
只有在那时，我们内在紧迫感的正当性动机，才能从此找到我们外在行动的细微需求，懂吗？
Did you notice the dead silence after she says, dig? In a room that only 30 minutes earlier had been filled with a noise that scared the cops. That's a lot of silence.
你注意到她说“懂吗”之后那死一般的寂静了吗？在一个仅仅30分钟前还充斥着让警察害怕的喧闹声的房间里。那真是长久的沉默。
So you were up there for, what, how long do you think? Two minutes or something like that?
你们在上面待了多久，你觉得？两分钟之类的？
It was two years.
待了两年。
Two years.
两年。
We were there for two years. We started at 24. We didn't know what we were doing. We didn't know if we finished the act or didn't finish the act. But the band leader had the punchline and he played, tada. And now, you want to see a couple of Jews standing there so nervous, looking to see if--
我们在那儿待了两年。我们开始时才24岁。我们不知道自己在做什么。我们不知道节目是演完了还是没演完。但乐队领队有笑点包袱，他弹奏了“塔达”。现在，你看看一对犹太夫妇站在那儿，多么紧张，看着是否——
If Mr. Sullivan is going to call us over.
沙利文先生会不会把我们叫过去。
--Ed would call us over because that's what makes you. Did he call us over? No.
——埃德会把我们叫过去，因为那才是让你成名的关键。他叫我们了吗？没有。
Yeah, but I think I saw-- no. Get off.
是啊，但我好像看见——不。让他们滚。
We were looking at each other saying, did he motion to us? Wasn't that a motion?
我们互相看着说，他向我们招手了吗？那不是个手势吗？
No, no get off.
不，不，让他们滚。
It wasn't. Get off.
不是。让他们滚。
Did you have a sense at the time that it had gone well or gone poorly?
当时你有没有感觉到演得好还是不好？
No, no. We knew immediately.
没有，没有。我们立即就知道。
No we knew-- into the toilet.
不，我们知道——演砸了。
Yeah. But see, they didn't have this expression then but, we sucked.
是啊。但是看，他们当时还没这个词，但我们演砸了。
It was, in fact, the worst three minutes of their lives. They bombed so bad that when they came off stage, people wouldn't look at them. Mitzi's mom dodged their call.
这其实是他们生命中最糟糕的三分钟。他们演砸得太惨，以至于下台后人们都不敢看他们。Mitzi的妈妈甚至回避了他们的电话。
The biggest terror was that we didn't want to go home.
最大的恐惧是我们不想回家。
We just didn't want to go home.
我们就是不想回家。
We did not want to go back to Los Angeles.
我们不想回到洛杉矶去。
But that night we felt so bad. And Frank Gorshin was nice enough to take us to Downey's.
但那天晚上我们感觉太糟了。幸好Frank Gorshin好心地带我们去了Downey餐厅。
Sardi's.
是Sardi's餐厅。
Sardi's. And we had a drink and he said, don't worry. This is not the end of your lives. And we said, oh my God.
Sardi's。我们喝了一杯，他说，别担心。这不是你们生命的终点。我们说，哦，天哪。
It was such a fiasco that in 40 years, neither of them have actually seen their performance. Until now. Watching a tape of it, the first thing Charlie noticed was that they actually did get a couple laughs.
这是一场如此巨大的惨败，以至于40年来，他们俩都没真正看过自己的那场表演。直到现在。看着录像带，Charlie注意到的第一件事是，他们其实确实引发了几次笑声。
It made me quite ill. Miss Tidy, send in the next young lady, please.
看得我真难受。Tidy小姐，请让下一位年轻女士进来。
Hi, sir. I'm the next young lady's mother. My little girl is waiting outside. She used to be one of The Beatles.
嗨，长官。我是下一位年轻女士的妈妈。我的小女儿在外面等着。她以前是披头士乐队的一员。
What happened?
发生什么了？
Somebody stepped on her. That was funny. You ad libbed that.
有人踩到她了。那个挺好笑的。那是你即兴发挥的。
You know something, Mitz? We were a hit.
你知道吗，Mitz？我们当时演得挺好。
No, you know what comes to--
不，你知道什么——
We were a hit. Look at us, cute.
我们演得挺好。看看我们，多可爱。
You know what? There's something wrong with you. It was pathetic.
你知道吗？你有毛病吧。那简直糟透了。
The problem, they both say, is that they had to rearrange their act for 14-year-olds in a hurry the day of the broadcast. They're still convinced that if they'd been invited on the show any other night, things would have been different. As it happened, they retreated back home, where their agent didn't call for six long months. From then on, they'd wince every time they heard The Beatles. Imagine that. They had the rest of the '60s ahead of them. They were in for a lot of wincing.
他们都说，问题在于那天广播当天，他们为了照顾14岁的观众，匆忙重排了节目。他们依然坚信，如果他们被邀请在其他任何一个晚上表演，结果都会不同。结果是他们退回老家，他们的经纪人有整整六个月没给他们打电话。从那以后，每当听到披头士，他们就会畏缩。想象一下。他们还得度过整个60年代呢。他们会有很多时间去畏缩。
But Mitzi and Charlie regrouped and recovered, and they had long and fine careers. Through the '60s and '70s, they played nightclubs and Vegas. And they were on television a lot, goofy stuff like The Gong Show , but great programs too like The Tonight Show , which they were on four times. Mitzi later wrote for sitcoms like Alf . Charlie eventually landed a leading role on a detective show called Silk Stalkings, which ran on the USA Network for nine years. They have a daughter whom they adore. No knock on Alf, but it gradually dawned on Mitzi and Charlie that on February 9, 1964, they were part of something seismic.
但Mitzi和Charlie重整旗鼓，恢复了过来，并拥有了长期且优秀的职业生涯。在60和70年代，他们活跃在夜总会和拉斯维加斯。他们经常上电视，演过像《Gong Show》那种搞怪节目，也演过像《今夜秀》那种很棒的节目，他们上过四次。Mitzi后来为《外星人阿福》等情景喜剧写过剧本。Charlie最终在一部名为《Silk Stalkings》的侦探剧中担任主角，该剧在美国电视网播出了九年。他们有一个深爱的女儿。这并不是贬低《外星人阿福》，但Mitzi和Charlie逐渐意识到，在1964年2月9日那天，他们参与了一件具有地震级影响的大事。
We were in the midst of greatness. We didn't know it. People would come up to us and say, wasn't that you that was on The Beatles show? And we said, yes, yes, waiting for them to say, boy, did you suck. And they went, oh my God, you're famous.
我们当时处于伟大时刻的中心，却浑然不知。人们会走过来对我们说，那个上过披头士节目的不是你们吗？我们说，是的，是的，等待他们说，“天哪，你们演得太烂了。”结果他们说，哦，天哪，你们是名人。
Mitzi and Charlie are retired now. Though last month they performed on stage for the first time in a couple decades, opening for their old friend, Ann-Margret. Meanwhile, The Beatles have split up. Hell, Wings have split up. But four decades after they flamed out in front of nearly half the country, Mitzi and Charlie are still together, still standing, and still refining the act.
Mitzi和Charlie现在退休了。虽然上个月他们几十年来第一次登台表演，为他们的老朋友Ann-Margret做开场嘉宾。与此同时，披头士解散了。天哪，Wings乐队也解散了。但在他们当着近半个国家观众搞砸演出四十年后，Mitzi和Charlie依然在一起，依然站在舞台上，并依然在打磨他们的表演。
I said to Dixie.
我对Dixie说。
Mitzi. Mitzi is my name.
Mitzi。Mitzi是我的名字。
Mitzi, Mitzi. I said to Mitzi, let's go to Florida.
Mitzi，Mitzi。我对Mitzi说，咱们去佛罗里达吧。
Did you call me Dixie?
你叫我Dixie了吗？
I think I may have.
我想我可能是叫了。
Who's Dixie?
Dixie是谁？
No, nobody.
没谁，没谁。
No, what do you have a girlfriend after--
不，难道你——
No, there's no Dixie.
不，没什么Dixie。
All right, never mind. It doesn't matter.
好吧，没关系。这不重要。
It was a slip. OK--
那是口误。好吧——
Dixie.
Dixie。
Forget the Dixie.
别管那个Dixie了。
What am I doing in this relationship?
我在这段关系里到底在干什么？
Anyway, I said to Mitzi--
总之，我对Mitzi说——
David Segal is a reporter with the New York Times . This weekend, Charlie and Mitzi celebrate their 49th wedding anniversary.
David Segal是《纽约时报》的记者。这个周末，Charlie和Mitzi庆祝他们结婚49周年纪念日。
Act Two. What Happens in Baghdad Stays in Baghdad. This next story is sort of the international version of starting in the mailroom and getting a big break. It begins when Jeff and Ray decide to spend a few months on vacation in a war zone. Jen Banbury met them when they showed up for dinner one night at the house she was sharing with a few other journalists in Baghdad. She lived there for 10 months writing about the war for Salon.com. Here's Jen.
第二幕，“巴格达发生的，留在巴格达”。接下来的这个故事算是国际版的“从基层员工开始获得重大转机”。它始于Jeff和Ray决定去战区度假几个月。Jen Banbury在巴格达时认识了他们，当时他们来到她和其他几位记者合住的房子吃晚饭。她在那儿住了10个月，为Salon.com写关于战争的报道。这是Jen的故事。
Jeff and Ray couldn't imagine not wanting to go to Baghdad. It was all they thought about for a while. They'd see it on the news and want to be there. They wanted to see it firsthand. They wanted to see a war zone, and they wanted to help. They had just spent a few weeks in the West Bank, volunteering with an ambulance crew. In Baghdad, they wanted to work.
Jeff和Ray无法想象为什么会有人不想去巴格达。他们有一段时间满脑子想的都是这个。他们在新闻里看到它，就想去那儿。他们想亲眼看看。他们想见识战区，并且想去帮忙。他们刚在约旦河西岸做过几周志愿者，和救护车队一起工作。在巴格达，他们想干活。
That was our goal all along, was to go over there and try to find work.
我们的目标一直就是去那边，试图找到工作。
We said-- oh, you know what I think our plan was? Two weeks, if we can't get a job--
我们说——哦，你知道我想我们的计划是什么吗？两周，如果我们找不到工作——
Yeah, we were going to split.
是啊，我们就撤。
We were going to split and we were going to go to Afghanistan or Africa, I think.
我们就撤，我想我们可能去阿富汗或非洲。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
Back in the States, they had been working at Fenway Park in Boston selling Cokes. They made enough money to travel, thanks to a simple idea. After years of hearing Boston fans yell, "Yankees suck," they decided to put the slogan on T-shirts and sell them at the games. So many drunk, diehard Red Sox fans bought them that Jeff and Ray could travel for months during the off-season using the profits.
回到美国后，他们曾在波士顿芬威球场卖可乐。多亏了一个简单的点子，他们赚到了足够的旅费。在听了波士顿球迷喊了几年“洋基队烂透了”之后，他们决定把这个标语印在T恤上卖给球迷。太多喝醉的红袜死忠粉买了这些衣服，以至于Jeff和Ray可以用赚来的钱在休赛期旅游几个月。
Getting into Iraq turned out to be surprisingly easy. From Israel, they made their way to Amman, Jordan. And from there, they found the cheapest way to get to Baghdad, public bus. It's a nine hour drive, but it ended up taking Jeff and Ray over 20, because the bus kept breaking down.
进入伊拉克比想象中容易。他们从以色列前往约旦安曼。从那里，他们找到了去巴格达最便宜的方法：公交车。这有9个小时的路程，但最终Jeff和Ray花了20多个小时，因为那辆车不停地抛锚。
It was pretty crazy. It was a quote, unquote, five star bus.
那太疯狂了。那是一辆所谓的“五星级”巴士。
What is a five star bus?
什么是五星级巴士？
That's what I'd like to know.
那也是我想知道的。
It was just the way that the Jordanians tried to sell us the product. "It's a five star bus. Very good Mr.--"
这只是约旦人试图把产品卖给我们的说法。“这是一辆五星级巴士，非常好，先生……”
They think five star means good. They have five star hotels, five star restaurants in Amman.
他们以为五星级就是好的意思。在安曼有五星级酒店、五星级餐厅。
Why not a five star bus?
为什么不能有五星级巴士？
Yeah, so we get to the bus terminal and it's bullet holes in the windows, fallen apart. We got on the bus, and it was like the record scratched when you walk in. It was like [RECORD SCRATCHING NOISE]. Me and Ray walk in. We're like-- what's going on, guys?
是啊，我们到了公交总站，那车窗上全是弹孔，破烂不堪。我们上了车，就像你走进房间时唱片停顿的声音一样。就像[唱片划伤的声音]。我和Ray走进去。我们想——伙计们，这到底怎么了？
We broke down in Fallujah, and we're like pissing on the side of the road, just like OK.
我们在费卢杰抛锚了，我们在路边撒尿，就像“好吧”。
And there was fighting going on. There were huge, black plumes of smoke coming up from the city. We were like, wow.
当时有战斗正在发生。巨大的黑色烟柱从城市升起。我们想，哇。
Were you starting to second guess it at all at that point? When you're seeing helicopters and smoke and--
那时候你开始产生怀疑了吗？当你看到直升机、烟雾和——
We just-- I think we had a little something to drink, or--
我们只是——我想我们喝了一点，或者——
Yeah. We had a few drinks.
是啊，我们喝了几杯。
Yeah, we weren't that concerned.
是啊，我们没那么担心。
It was that easy. They were in. No credentials, no papers. When they finally got to Baghdad, Jeff and Ray were half asleep, half drunk, and had no idea where they were going. They remembered the name of a hotel that they had read about in the news where journalists supposedly stayed, and they got a taxi to take them there. Right away, they started looking for jobs with private companies and with the CPA, the Coalition Provisional Authority that was running Iraq at the time.
就这么简单。他们进去了。没有证件，没有文件。当他们最终到达巴格达时，Jeff和Ray半梦半醒、醉醺醺的，根本不知道要去哪里。他们记得新闻里读到过一家酒店的名字，据说记者们都住那儿，于是他们打车去了那里。他们立刻开始寻找私人公司和CPA的工作，即当时管理伊拉克的“驻伊拉克联军临时管理当局”。
We had applied for every job in Iraq.
我们申请了伊拉克所有的工作。
Everybody in the CPA, when they first met us was like, so how exactly did you get here? And then they would just laugh and scratch their heads and stuff.
CPA里的每个人第一次见到我们时都问：那你们到底是怎么进来的？然后他们就只是笑笑，挠挠头之类。
But the CPA desperately needed people to help run parts of the government that had never existed under Saddam. And desperation breeds opportunity. Jeff and Ray actually ended up getting pretty important jobs, coordinating about 400 Iraqi organizations that had sprung up to distribute clothes and school supplies, and tons of other donations coming in from the States.
但CPA迫切需要人来帮助运作萨达姆统治下从未存在过的政府部门。绝望滋生机会。Jeff和Ray最终竟然得到了相当重要的工作，负责协调400个已经建立起来的伊拉克组织，分发衣服、学校用品以及从美国运来的大量捐赠物资。
We had airport hangars full of donated clothing and stuff.
我们的机场机库里堆满了捐赠的衣物之类的东西。
And did you have any experience in doing stuff like that from before?
你们之前有做过这种事的经验吗？
Yeah, the T-shirts. Because our whole thing was, I'm never carrying a box. We always had to carry these boxes, because we made the shirts. We were like, we're never carrying boxes again.
有啊，卖T恤的时候。因为我们整套东西就是……我再也不想搬箱子了。我们以前总是得搬这些箱子，因为是我们制作衣服。我们当时说，我们再也不搬箱子了。
We swore it off forever.
我们发誓再也不碰箱子了。然后我们到了伊拉克，我们的工作就是搬箱子。我记得，我看Jeff在分类。我走进去——
We swore off boxes. And then we show up in Iraq and our job is boxes. I remember, I'd see Jeff sorting. I'd come in and--
就像一种闪回。
It'd be like a flashback.
那简直就是闪回。他当时就说，我想自杀。
It would just be a flashback. And he'd just be like, I want to kill myself.
他们立刻开始了每天16小时的工作。因为他们不在乎是否遵守所有规则，他们实际上比CPA里很多人做成了更多事。例如，他们会去萨德尔城——巴格达郊区的一个巨大贫民窟——那是一个大多数美国人从不去的地方，因为按照规则，他们应该在武装护送下才能去那里。
They were immediately working 16-hour days. And because they didn't care about following all the rules, they were actually able to get more done than lots of people at the CPA. For instance, they'd go to Sadr City, a huge slum on the outskirts of Baghdad, and a place most Americans never went because, under the rules, they were only supposed to travel there in an armed convoy.
事实上，大多数西方人从未离开过“绿区”——巴格达市中心那个戒备森严的堡垒。Jeff和Ray想出去和伊拉克人一起工作。他们开始频繁前往萨德尔城，既没有武器，也没有军事护送。
In fact, most westerners never left the Green Zone, the fortified compound in the middle of Baghdad. Jeff and Ray wanted to be out working with Iraqis. They started going to Sadr City a lot, without weapons or a military escort.
那是巴格达的一个贫民窟，萨达姆把大多数什叶派放在那里，基本上让他们生活在贫民窟里。你走进那里，街中央流着两英尺宽的原始污水，医院大厅里、学校里，到处都是。
And it's one slum area of Baghdad where Saddam put most of the Shiites and he just made them live in a slum, basically. You go in there and there's two feet of raw sewage running down the middle of the streets, inside the hallways of hospitals, schools, everything.
街上有驴子在吃原始污水，孩子们连鞋都没有。这是最主要的问题之一，孩子们没鞋穿，我们总是尝试给他们带鞋，那是——
Donkeys on the street eating raw sewage, kids with no shoes on. That was one of the major things was kids didn't have shoes, and we would always try to bring them the shoes and it was--
我从未见过这样的场景。太疯狂了。我们在办公室里待着，我们讨厌它，在办公室里我们想自杀，但只要到了萨德尔城，感觉就棒极了。那太好了。我们整天都在那儿和小孩子们踢足球之类的。太酷了。这让我们感觉很好。因为我们从外面回到办公室，每一天都感觉像是生命中最美好的一天。
I've never seen anything like it. It was crazy. We were in the office and we hated it, we'd want to kill ourselves in the office but we'd get to Sadr City and it was the best. It was great. We'd just go out there and play soccer with little kids all day and stuff. It was cool. It just made us feel good. Because we'd get back to the office from being out there, and it would be like every day was the best day of our lives.
几乎每天，Jeff和Ray都会离开“绿区”，去一家烟草店下西洋双陆棋，和那些非常喜欢他们的老人们聊天，尽管他们并不确定该怎么看待这些人。我曾经和Jeff、Ray一起去过那家店，感觉就像在《Cheers》剧集里。每个人都认识他们，当他们进来时会大声问候。店离“绿区”只有一个街区，但他们几乎是唯一去那里的美国人。他们和伊拉克人一起喝茶、抽水烟。
Almost every day, Jeff and Ray left the Green Zone and went to a tobacco shop where they played backgammon and hung out with the old men who adored them, even if they weren't exactly sure what to make of them. I visited the shop with Jeff and Ray once and it was like Cheers . Everyone knew them and greeted them loudly when they came in. The shop was just a block away from the Green Zone, but they were pretty much the only Americans who ever went there. They'd drink tea and smoke narghile pipes with the Iraqi guys.
伊拉克有酒水店，还有药品法律相当宽松的药店。你可以走进一家药店买液体安定和许多其他潜在的娱乐性药物，不需要处方。许多西方人在巴格达都有一定程度的自我药疗。但Jeff和Ray比我们大多数人更知道怎么弄到这些东西。
There are liquor stores in Iraq and drugstores where pharmaceutical laws are pretty lax. You can walk into a drugstore and buy liquid Valium and a host of other potential recreational drugs without a prescription. Lots of westerners do a certain amount of self-medicating in Baghdad. But Jeff and Ray knew more about how to get that stuff than most of us.
我在那里得到了“训练轮”的外号，因为我摔倒了太多次。我记得我在三个花园里晕倒过——你的花园，阿尔哈姆拉酒店的花园。
I got the nickname of Training Wheels over there, because I fell over so much. I passed out in three gardens that I can think of-- your garden, the garden at Al Hamrah.
是啊，我在阿尔哈姆拉的浴室地板上晕倒过。
Yeah, I passed out on the bathroom floor in Al Hamrah.
——在游泳池区域的花园里。
--In the garden at the pool area.
他们会闯入福克斯新闻和NBC举办的聚会。他们和那些总有大麻的法国人混在一起。他们在轰炸期间喝酒。
They'd crash parties thrown by FOX News and NBC. They hung out with these French guys who always had pot. They drank during bombardments.
他们说，下到防空洞去。你就问，他们有酒吗？然后他们——
They say, go downstairs to the bomb shelter. And you say, do they have booze? Then they--
事实上，他们在防空洞里开了一个酒吧。
Actually, they opened a bar in the bomb shelter.
是啊。我们当时在阿尔拉希德酒店。那是我们每天吃晚饭的地方。突然间，八九枚火箭弹击中了阿尔拉希德的前脸。感觉大楼都要塌了。烟雾开始涌入餐厅。每个人都趴在地上。我们做着战术匍匐爬行[消音]。他们把我们推下楼进了——
Yeah. We were in the Al-Rasheed. That's where we ate dinner every night. And all of a sudden like eight or nine rockets hit the face of Al-Rasheed. And it just felt like the building was going to come down. Smoke starts billowing into the dining hall. Everybody's laying on the ground. We're doing army crawls and [BLEEP.] And they shuffled us downstairs into--
防空洞。
The bomb shelter.
——那个防空洞。结果那竟是一个体育酒吧。他们有一台带卫星信号的宽屏电视。他们在播放CNN。他们说——
--the bomb shelter. But it turned out to be a sports bar. And they had a big, widescreen TV with satellite. And they had CNN on. And they're like--
是我们的大楼在烧。
It was our building burning.
——看，阿尔拉希德酒店遭到火箭袭击。窗户喷出了火焰。我们坐在那儿，在酒吧里，看着我们刚才所在的大楼燃烧。我们当时想，什么情况？
--here's the Al-Rasheed under rocket attack. And there's flames billowing out of windows. And we're sitting in there, in the bar, watching the building we were in burn. We were just like, what?
然后他们把频道切换回了一场橄榄球比赛。
And then they switched the channel back to a rugby game.
当Jeff和Ray到达伊拉克时，令人震惊的是那里的西方援助组织竟然这么少。在联合国和红十字会遭受炸弹袭击后，大多数组织撤离了，这意味着援助工作几乎处于停滞状态。对于所有那些努力重建伊拉克的美国官员，我见过的更多人是为了花三个月时间充实简历然后离开。相比之下，Jeff和Ray简直是圣徒。他们只是想和伊拉克人待在一起，做好工作。如果你正在重建一个国家，而一切都在混乱之中，那么他们的表现比很多人都要强。
By the time Jeff and Ray got to Iraq, it was kind of shocking how few Western aid groups were there. Most had pulled out after the UN and Red Cross bombings in the fall, meaning aid work was almost at a standstill. And for all the American officials who are working really hard to rebuild Iraq, I met even more who are there to spend three months beefing up their resumes and get out. Compared to that, Jeff and Ray were saints. They simply wanted to hang out with Iraqis and do good work. If you're rebuilding a country and everything's chaos, you could do a lot worse than them.
Jeff和Ray在面对真实的危险时完成了这些工作。他们和与他们一起工作的人都成了被针对的目标。每个星期二，他们都会为与之合作的所有非政府组织在“绿区”大门口附近举行一次大型会议。
And Jeff and Ray did this work in the face of real danger. They and the people who worked with them were getting personally targeted. Every Tuesday, they'd have a big meeting for all the non-governmental organizations they worked with, right near the gate to the Green Zone.
然后他们开始——有人连续三个星期二在12:30试图在大门口自杀式炸弹袭击。
Then they started-- people tried to suicide bomb the front gate three Tuesdays in a row at like 12:30.
我们肯定问过人们，那个炸弹是怎么回事？
We were definitely asking people, what was up with that bomb?
是啊，为什么他们每天试图炸同一个大门？
Yeah, how come they try to bomb the same gate every day?
那太奇怪了。为什么每个星期二12:30都有炸弹、威胁或引信被发现。
That's weird. How come every Tuesday at 12:30 there's a bomb found, or threat, or a detonator.
真的是连续三个星期。
Literally three weeks in a row.
是啊，有一次我们听到一声巨响，看到一个轮胎飞过。我们当时真是容易上当。他们说，哦不，那不是——
Yeah, one time we hear a boom and see a tire flying. And we were so gullible. They were like, oh no, that was not--
是啊，那不是针对你们的。
Yeah, that wasn't for you guys.
那和你们毫无关系。
That was nothing to do with you guys.
最终，威胁和爆炸尝试意味着Jeff和Ray不得不提前离开，在他们觉得准备好之前。所以他们不得不选择一个人来接手他们开始的工作。决定并不难。有一个叫Haider的家伙，他们是在萨德尔城合作的。他总是开车带他们去那儿。他成了他们的左膀右臂。
Eventually the threats and the bombing attempts meant that Jeff and Ray had to leave early, before they felt ready. So they had to choose someone to take over the work they had started. It wasn't hard to decide. There was this guy, Haider, who they worked with in Sadr City. He'd drive them out there all the time. He became their right hand man.
由于他们不想让他像他们当时那样毫无准备地承担工作，Jeff和Ray送他去贝鲁特参加了一个非政府组织领导力会议。选择Haider是喜忧参半的。他们知道他是这份工作的最佳人选，但也知道这可能会让他陷入危险。
Since they didn't want him to go into the job unprepared, like they had been, Jeff and Ray sent him to a non-governmental organization leadership conference in Beirut. It was bittersweet choosing Haider. They knew he was the best person for the job. But they also knew the danger it might put him in.
所以我们上了这趟航班。
So we got on this flight.
他这辈子都没离开过巴格达。
Never left Baghdad in his life.
没有。显然他从未坐过飞机。在贝鲁特住五星级酒店。
No. And he'd never flown, obviously. And a five star hotel in Beirut.
我们本应该直接告诉Haider，去黎巴嫩就别回来了。
We should have just told Haider, go to Lebanon and never come back.
我们确实告诉过他。
We did tell him.
We did tell him that.
当我们给他飞机票时，我们说，伙计，你不必回来了。
When we gave him the plane ticket we were like, dude, you don't have to come back.
但我们本应该——
But we should have--
我们说，薅客房服务的羊毛，记在美国政府账上。
We're like, milk the room service with the room, and charge it to the US government.
美国国际开发署说你不给客房服务？那就把迷你吧毁了。
USAID says that you're not getting room service? Destroy that minibar.
是啊，我们说想想迷你吧，客房服务。我们只是说薅羊毛。我们告诉他——我们说，你不必回来了。但他回来了。
Yeah, we're like think minibar, room service. We're just like milk it. We told him-- we were like, you don't have to come back. But he did.
我们得知的情况是——有四个武装分子在他从家前往“绿区”的路上尾随他，在停车检查点杀了他。因为这个——
What we were told-- it was four gunmen followed him from his house, while he was on his way to the Green Zone, killed him at a traffic stop. Because of that--
我们选中他是因为他——是我们害死了他。而且……我不知道。
We chose him because he was-- we got him killed. And-- I don't know.
当他们回顾在巴格达的时光时，Jeff和Ray大多将其视为一次失败。他们运营的援助项目已经不存在了。他们最好的朋友因为他们而死。他们依然很难谈论Haider。他们只是真的很敬佩他。他在做他们所做的所有工作，此外还要完成博士学位，照顾13个兄弟姐妹。在他们共同在伊拉克工作的几个月里，他把他们当成了兄弟。他让他们感觉伊拉克的一切可能会好转。
When they look back on their time in Baghdad, Jeff and Ray mostly see it as a failure. The aid program they ran doesn't exist anymore. They got their best friend killed. It's still hard for them to talk about Haider. They just really admired him. He was doing all the work they were doing, plus finishing his PhD and taking care of 13 siblings. During the months they worked with him in Iraq, he treated them like brothers too. And he made them feel like everything in Iraq might just turn out OK.
记者Jen Banbury采访了Jeff Neumann和Ray Lemoine。他们有一本关于这段经历的书，叫《Babylon by Bus》。接下来，一个孩子试图通过驾驭某种最强大的力量来修复家庭。稍后从芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际带来的节目继续。
Reporter Jen Banbury with Jeff Neumann and Ray Lemoine. They have a book about their experience called Babylon by Bus . Coming up, a child tries to fix his family by harnessing the most powerful force there is. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同类型的相关故事。今天的节目是“我的大转机”，讲述人们在获得幸运的重大机会后发生的事情。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“俄狄浦斯之咒”。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "My Big Break," stories of what happens to people after they get their big lucky chance. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Oedipus Hex.
Shalom Auslander讲述了这个发生在他儿时的一所被称为“叶史瓦”的极端正统派犹太教学校里的故事。警告听众：虽然这个故事是关于一个小男孩的，但它可能在某些方面不太适合所有孩子。
Shalom Auslander tells this story which happened to him when he was a boy in one of the ultra-Orthodox Jewish religious schools called Yeshivas. Warning to listeners that although the story is about a little boy, it might be, in some very mild way, not for every child.
Brier拉比走进我们的三年级教室，挂上他那件长黑大衣，摘下他那顶大黑帽，给每位学生发了一本名为《祝福指南》的小黑书。他告诉我们，我们要用一周时间准备一年一度的叶史瓦（Spring Valley）祝福竞赛。我的心跳加速。这正是妈妈所需要的。祝福竞赛会让她忘记家里所有的烦恼。能有一个儿子成为“talmid chacham”，即明智的学生，那才是最终的成就。她的兄弟是一位受人尊敬的拉比，如果她的丈夫做不到，好吧，也许她的儿子能做到。
Rabbi Brier walked into our third grade classroom, hung up his long black coat, took off his big black hat, and handed each student a small, black booklet entitled The Guide to Blessings . We had one week, he told us, to prepare for the annual Yeshiva of Spring Valley Blessing Bee. My heart leapt. This was just what my mother needed. The Blessing Bee would make her forget all of the troubles of her home. To have a son who's a talmid chacham, a wise student, that was the ultimate. Her brother was a respected rabbi, and if her husband couldn't be one, well, maybe her son could be.
《祝福指南》是一本70页长的书，列出了数百种不同的食物，分成了不同的章节。汤、面包、鱼、甜点。我翻着书，慢慢意识到前方挑战的规模。法拉费（油炸鹰嘴豆饼）、鲱鱼、茄子帕尔马干酪。我有得忙了。
The Guide to Blessings was a 70-page long listing of hundreds of different foods divided into different chapters. Soups, breads, fish, desserts. I flipped through it, slowly realizing the size of the challenge that lay ahead. Falafel, herring, eggplant parmesan. I had my work cut out for me.
周五下午，叶史瓦会提前关门，以便我们都能赶回家帮父母准备安息日（Shabbos）。Brier拉比告诉我们，圣贤告诉我们，托拉告诉我们，为安息日的准备工作与安息日本身一样重要。我大部分准备工作包括搜遍全家寻找犹太教葡萄酒，然后把它们倒进厕所。这是一个没人知道的吃力不讨好的工作。如果没喝到马尼谢维茨（Manischewitz）康科德葡萄甜酒，父亲那种挫败的愤怒非常可怕，但比起他喝醉后的狂暴，这要好得多。我会搜遍食品储藏室、车库，搜遍父亲的衣柜。但我只有8岁，而且总有一瓶凯登酒藏在我想不到的地方。
Friday afternoons, the yeshiva closed early so that we could all rush home to help our parents prepare for Shabbos, the Sabbath. Rabbi Brier told us that the sages tell us that the Torah tells us that the preparation for Shabbos is equal to the importance of Shabbos itself. Most of my preparations involved searching the house for kosher wine and pouring it down the toilet. It was a thankless job I admitted to nobody. My father's frustrated rage at not having his Manischewitz Concord Grape was fearsome, but it was far better than his drunken rage if he did have it. I'd search the pantry. I'd search the garage. I'd search my father's closet. But I was only eight years old. And there was always a bottle of Kedem hiding somewhere I just hadn't thought to check.
那天晚上，父亲因为喝了一瓶侥幸躲过我的桃红夏布利酒而醉倒，他抓住我哥哥的衬衫领子，把他从安息日餐桌旁拖走。他一直把他拖下楼梯，拖进地下室的卧室，砰地一声关上门。连餐具都跳动了一下。
That night my father, drunk on a bottle of blush Chablis that got away, grabbed my older brother by his shirt collar and dragged him away from the Shabbos table. He dragged him all the way down the stairs to our bedroom in the basement and slammed the door shut. Even the silverware jumped.
“谁想要最后一个犹太团子？”妈妈问。我多做了一些。当哥哥回到餐桌时，他的鼻子在流血。妈妈拿来一罐冷冻橙汁让他贴在后颈，据说这能止血。Brier拉比教导我们，在安息日解冻橙汁是禁止的，因为将食物从固体变为液体被认为是烹饪。而烹饪被认为是工作。即使上帝也在安息日休息。
"Who wants the last matzoh ball?" my mother asked. I made extra. When my brother returned to the table, his nose was bleeding. My mother brought him a can of frozen orange juice to hold against the back of his neck, which was supposed to somehow stop the bleeding. Rabbi Brier taught us that it is prohibited to defrost orange juice on Shabbos because changing food from solid to liquid is considered cooking. And cooking is considered working. And even God refrained from working on Shabbos.
安息日有39种禁止的劳动分类。这就是为什么你不被允许在安息日开灯的原因。电流导致灯丝发光，被认为是在燃烧，被认为是在工作——属于第二类。
There are 39 different categories of work that are prohibited on Shabbos. That's also why you're not allowed to switch on lights on Shabbos. The electricity causes the filament to glow, which is considered burning, which is considered working-- category number two.
父亲回到餐桌旁，醉醺醺地唱了几首安息日歌曲，歌词乱七八糟，还用拳头用力砸桌子。我弓着身子坐着，心不在焉地在银水壶的冷凝水上画圆圈。父亲打了我的手一下。
My father came back to the table and drunkenly sang a few Shabbos songs, fudging the words and banging heavily on the table with his fist. I sat hunched over, absent-mindedly drawing circles on the condensation that had formed on the silver water pitcher. My father slapped my hand.
“安息日，”他吼道。书写——属于第五类。最终他踉踉跄跄地走向卧室，倒头大睡，鼾声如雷。我们坐在餐厅里，闷闷不乐地拨弄着食物。
"Shabbos," he shouted. Writing-- category number five. Eventually he stumbled off to his bedroom and fell asleep snoring loudly. We sat in the dining room and picked glumly at our food.
接下来的周一早上，当我们都在学习祝福书时，Brier拉比的教室门被敲响了。叶史瓦校长Greenbaum拉比严肃地走了进来。我们都站了起来。两位拉比低声商量了一会儿，才示意我们坐下。在深思熟虑地抚摸了一阵他那长长的黑胡子后，Greenbaum拉比深深地叹了口气，告诉我们，前一天晚上，我们同学Avrumi Gruenembaum的父亲心脏病发作去世了。有些孩子真是走运。
The following Monday morning, as we all sat studying from our blessing books, there was a knock on Rabbi Brier's classroom door. And Rabbi Greenbaum, the Yeshiva principal, solemnly entered. We all rose. The two rabbis conferred quietly for a moment, before signaling us all to be seated. After a few thoughtful strokes of his long black beard, Rabbi Greenbaum sighed deeply and informed us that the night before, our classmate Avrumi Gruenembaum's father had suffered a heart attack and died. Some kids have all the luck.
“祝福唯一真审判者，”Brier拉比点头说。
"Blessed is the one true judge," said Rabbi Brier nodding his head.
“祝福唯一真审判者，”我们都回答，点点头。我好奇Gruenembaum先生做了什么事要遭遇死亡。他崇拜偶像了吗？他没戴小圆帽走了四步路了吗？无论是什么，那一定非常糟糕。当Greenbaum拉比转身离开时，他停下来，用严厉的手指摇了摇，提醒我们所有人：圣贤告诉我们，托拉告诉我们，13岁之前，男孩的所有罪孽都归咎于他的父亲。
"Blessed is the one true judge," we all answered, nodding our heads. I wondered what Mr. Gruenembaum might have done to deserve death. Did he bow down to idols? Did he walk four steps without his yarmulke on? Whatever it was, it must have been pretty bad. As Rabbi Greenbaum turned to leave, he paused and with a stern shake of his finger reminded us all that the sages tell us that the Torah tells us that until the age of 13, all of a boy's sins are ascribed to his father.
我转头去看Avrumi空着的椅子。Avrumi是个戴着牙套、口臭严重的胖孩子。但一种突如其来的敬畏在他身上升起。我想知道他可能做了什么事导致他父亲的死亡。无论是什么，那一定非常糟糕。Greenbaum拉比狠狠地瞪着眼，建议我们每个人都向Hashem——神圣的主，受祝福者——祈求宽恕，这样他就不会也杀掉我们的父亲。我的心跳加速。
I turned to look at Avrumi's empty chair. Avrumi was a chubby kid with heavy orthodontia and foul breath. But a sudden respect for him grew inside me. I wondered what he might have done to cause his father's death. Whatever it was, it must have been pretty bad. Scowling fiercely, Rabbi Greenbaum advised each and every one of us to pray to Hashem-- the Holy One Blessed Be He-- for forgiveness so that he wouldn't kill our fathers too. My heart leapt.
“祝福Hashem，”他说。
"Blessed is Hashem," he said.
“祝福Hashem，”我们回答。祝福Hashem是对的。突然间，我有两种拯救家庭的方法。我可以为妈妈赢得祝福竞赛，或者我可以犯下这么多罪，以至于Hashem不得不杀掉我的父亲。勇敢的Avrumi Gruenembaum，也许某个安息日的晚上他开过灯，也许他吃完肉喝过奶，也许他自慰过。那天晚上，临睡前，我吃了一根鸡腿，喝了一杯牛奶，自慰了，还反复开关了卧室的灯。
"Blessed is Hashem," we answered. Blessed is Hashem was right. All of a sudden I had two ways I could save my family. I could win the Blessing Bee for my mother, or I could sin so much, Hashem would have to kill my father. Courageous Avrumi Gruenembaum, maybe one Shabbos night he had switched on a light. Maybe he drank milk after eating meat. Maybe he touched himself. That night, just before bed, I ate a drumstick, washed it down with some milk, touched myself, and flicked the bedroom light on and off.
“把那些灯弄坏了我就打断你的手，”父亲吼道。这将是忙碌的一周。
"Break those lights and I'll break your hands," my father shouted. It was going to be a busy week.
祝福竞赛的规则和拼写竞赛一样。食物有六种基本祝福——Hamotzei（面包祝福）、Mezonos（小麦祝福）、Hagofen（酒或葡萄汁祝福）、Ha-eitz（树木生长之物的祝福）、Ho-adamah（大地生长之物的祝福）、以及Shehakol（其他一切食物的祝福）。
The Blessing Bee worked the same way as a spelling bee. There are six basic blessings on food-- hamotzei, the blessing for bread, mezonos, the blessing for wheat, hagofen, the blessing for wine or grape juice, ha-eitz, the blessing for things that grow from trees, ho-adamah, the blessing for things that grow from the earth, and shehakol, the blessing for everything else.
贝果？Hamotzei。燕麦片？Mezonos。犹太鱼丸？Shehakol（万物祝福）。但这只是简单的部分。当你开始组合食物时，事情变得复杂得多。有些食物比其他食物优越，在与次要食物组合时，优越的食物获得祝福权。更糟糕的是，有些祝福比其他祝福更优越，你必须知道先念哪个祝福。这就是在这里区分男人和外邦人的地方。
Bagel? Hamotzei. Oatmeal? Mezonos. Gefilte fish? Shehakol, the blessing for everything else. But that was the easy part. Things became much more complicated when you started combining foods. Some foods are superior to other foods, and in combination with subordinate foods, the superior food gets the blessing. To make matters worse, some blessings are superior to other blessings and you had to know which blessing to recite first. This is where they separated the men from the goys.
意大利面和肉丸？Mezonos，小麦祝福。然后Shehakol，万物祝福。谷物加牛奶？Shehakol（牛奶祝福），然后Mezonos（谷物里的小麦祝福）。Twix（带曲奇脆片的巧克力糖）？陷阱题。Twix不是犹太洁食。
Spaghetti and meatballs? Mezonos, the wheat blessing. Then shehakol, the everything else blessing. Cereal with milk? Shehakol for the milk, then mezonos for the wheat in the cereal. Twix, the chocolate candy with the cookie crunch? Trick question. Twix isn't kosher.
我花了一周时间犯罪和祝福，祝福和犯罪，交替赞美上帝然后尽可能地对抗他，就像一个8岁孩子能做到的那样。周一早上，我狼吞虎咽。我吃了一碗Fruity Pebbles麦片——Mezonos；一片吐司——Hamotzei；一杯果汁——Shehakol；半个苹果——Ha-eitz；还有我在冰箱底部找到的几根旧薯条——Ho-adamah。一顿饭，五个祝福。
I spent the next week sinning and blessing, and blessing and sinning, alternately praising God and then defying him as much as one eight-year-old possibly could. Monday morning, I stuffed myself. I had a bowl of Fruity Pebbles-- mezonos, a slice of toast-- hamotzei, a glass of juice-- shehakol, half an apple-- ha-eitz, and a couple of old french fries I found at the bottom of the fridge-- ho-adamah. One meal, five blessings.
周二，我自慰了。我还吃了面包，却没有举行饭前洗手仪式。那天晚上，睡觉前，我坐在床边，小心翼翼地 recite[消音]、[消音]，还有“混蛋”各十几遍。父亲愤怒地敲我的卧室门。
Tuesday I touched myself. I also partook of bread without first ceremoniously washing my hands. And that evening, before going to sleep, I sat on the edge of my bed and carefully recited [BLEEP], [BLEEP], and ass a dozen times each. My father banged angrily on my bedroom door.
“关灯，”他咆哮。
"Lights out," he barked.
我笑着说：“伙计，对咱俩都适用。”
I smiled, "For you and me both, pal."
周三，我从妈妈那儿偷了5美元，买了包糖，但我根本没给那包糖做任何祝福。其中有一根查尔斯顿咀嚼糖（本来就是不洁的），还有一块Chunky，如果我不是想杀掉父亲的话，那本来是Shehakol。Chunky配葡萄干？Shehakol，然后Ha-eitz。
Wednesday I stole $5 from my mother and didn't recite any blessings at all on the bag full of candy that I brought with it. A Charleston Chew, which is traif to begin with, and a Chunky, which would have been a shehakol if I weren't trying to kill my father. A Chunky with raisins? Shehakol then ha-eitz.
周四，我没戴流苏（tzitzis）。Brier拉比注意到我的衣服边上没有流苏下垂，揪住我的耳朵把我拉到教室前。
Thursday I didn't wear tzitzis. Rabbi Brier noticed that the strings weren't dangling from my sides and grabbed me by the ear and pulled me to the front of the class.
“告诉以色列的孩子们，”他大声引用托拉的话，同时用力拍打我的屁股，“告诉他们要在衣服的角落上做流苏。”
"Speak to the children of Israel," he quoted loudly from the Torah as he spanked me hard on my bottom. "And tell them to make tzitzis on the corners of their garments."
那天下午，在妈妈叫我倒垃圾但我没理会，没表现出对长辈的尊重之后，我自慰了，并默默乞求上帝——就这一次——把那些罪行记在Brier拉比的账上。后来我带着祈祷书进了洗手间，玷污了它。祝福竞赛就在第二天早上，我几乎彻夜难眠。扁豆汤，Mezonos。土豆馅饼，Ho-adamah。根汁汽水（Root beer）。它是根吗？它是啤酒吗？[消音]、[消音]、混蛋、贱人。我翻来覆去。我祝福并咒骂。最后陷入了不安的睡眠。
That afternoon, after not respecting my elders by taking out the garbage like my mother had told me to, I touched myself and silently begged God to-- just this once-- credit those sins to Rabbi Brier's account. Later I defiled a prayer book by carrying it into the bathroom. The Blessing Bee was the following morning and I could barely sleep. Lentil soup, mezonos. Potato knish, ho-adamah. Root beer. Is it a root? Is it a beer? [BLEEP], [BLEEP], ass, bitch. I tossed and turned. I blessed and cursed. And finally I fell into an uncomfortable sleep.
经过一周在家的休整，Avrumi Gruenembaum及时回到了学校参加祝福竞赛。我竭力忍住没转头去问他是怎么做到的。嘘，Avrumi，告诉我，是龙虾吗？你吃龙虾了吗？Brier拉比告诉我们，圣贤说，托拉说，当亚伯拉罕去世时，Hashem安慰了以撒。我们从中得知，安慰丧亲者是一种巨大的“mitzva”，即善行。
After a week at home, Avrumi Gruenembaum conveniently returned to school just in time for the Blessing Bee. It was all I could do to not lean over and ask him how he did it. Psst, Avrumi, tell me, was it lobster? Did you eat lobster? Rabbi Brier told us that the sages tell us that the Torah tells us that when Abraham died, Hashem comforted Isaac. We learn from this that it is a tremendous mitzvah, or good deed, to comfort the bereaved.
Brier拉比指示我们所有人排队站在Avrumi的桌边，握住他的手，念诵传统的哀悼安慰语——“愿Hashem在锡安的哀悼者中安慰你。”作为一个8岁的孩子，我并不完全熟悉Hashem的系统。但我想到，除了我所有的罪孽，父亲可能也在得到我所有的功德。我可不想冒这个险。很快就轮到我了。
Rabbi Brier instructed us all to line up at Avrumi's desk, to shake his hand and recite the traditional mourner's consolation-- "May Hashem comfort you among the mourners of Zion." Being just eight years old, I wasn't entirely familiar with Hashem's system. But it occurred to me that, along with all my sins, my father might also be getting all my mitzvahs. I wasn't taking any chances. Soon it was my turn in line.
“最近怎么样？”我对Avrumi说。Brier拉比掐了我一下。“噢！”我尖叫道。
"How's it going?" I said to Avrumi. Rabbi Brier pinched me. "Ow!" I screamed.
“笨蛋，”他嘟囔。
"Shmendrik," he grumbled.
最后一个男孩祈求Hashem在锡安的哀悼者中安慰Avrumi后，Brier拉比重重拍了下桌子。祝福竞赛开始了。
After the last boy had asked Hashem to comfort Avrumi among the mourners of Zion, Rabbi Brier smacked his desk loudly. The Blessing Bee began.
我们在教室后面排好队，紧张地拉着我们的流苏，打着我们的鬓角。规则很简单。念出正确的祝福并留在原地进入下一轮。念错祝福，你就坐回座位。
We lined up at the back of the classroom, nervously pulling on our tzitzis and twirling our peyis. The rules were simple. Name the correct blessing and remain standing for the next round. Name the wrong blessing, and you take your seat.
去年的冠军Yukisiel Zalman Yehuda Schneck站在我身边。他冷静地靠在墙上，漫无目的地抠着鼻子。
Last year's winner, Yukisiel Zalman Yehuda Schneck, stood beside me. He leaned calmly against the wall, mindlessly picking his nose.
“Auslander，Shalom，”Brier拉比喊道。我走上前。“苹果，”他大喊。
"Auslander, Shalom," called out Rabbi Brier. I stepped forward. "Apple," he shouted.
“苹果，”我大喊。“Ha-eitz”，树木生长之物的祝福。
"Apple," I called out. "Ha-eitz," the blessing for food from trees.
“正确，”Brier拉比说。祝福竞赛通常开始得很简单。David Borgen得到了金枪鱼——Shehakol，万物祝福。Ari Mashinsky得到了犹太无酵饼——Hamotzei，面包祝福。Avi Tuchman被库格尔（Kugel）卡住了，他以为是Ho-adamah（大地祝福），但实际上是Mezonos（小麦祝福）。另外三个孩子被燕麦片淘汰。甜菜汤配酸奶油又淘汰了两个。到第一轮结束时，近三分之一的学生已经回到了座位上。
"Correct," Rabbi Brier said. The Blessing Bee usually started off pretty easy. David [? Borgen ?] got tuna-- shehakol, the everything else blessing. Ari Mashinsky got matzoh-- hamotzei, the blessing for bread. And Avi Tuchman got stuck with kugel, which he thought was ho-adamah, food from the earth, but was really mezonos, the blessing on wheat. Three other kids got taken out by oatmeal. Borscht with sour cream claimed two others. And by the end of the first round, almost a third of the students were already back in their seats.
第二轮。“Auslander，Shalom，”Brier拉比叫道。我走上前。“蘑菇大麦汤，”他喊道。
Round two. "Auslander, Shalom," called Rabbi Brier. I stepped forward. "Mushroom barley soup," he shouted.
蘑菇大麦汤，蘑菇大麦汤。该死。我知道我应该多复习汤类那一章。我把一半时间都浪费在主菜上了。是蘑菇的Ho-adamah（大地祝福）吗？还是大麦的Mezonos（小麦祝福）？也许是Shehakol，万物祝福？“蘑菇大麦汤，”我喊道。“Mezonos。”
Mushroom barley soup, mushroom barley soup. Damn. I knew I should have studied the chapter on soups more. I'd wasted half the week on entrees. Was it ho-adamah on the mushrooms which came from the earth? Or was it mezonos on the barley? Maybe it was shehakol , the everything else blessing, on the soup. "Mushroom barley soup," I called out. "Mezonos."
Brier拉比拉扯着胡子，眼睛眯成了愤怒的小缝。“还有Shehakol，”我补充道。Brier拉比胜利地拍了下桌子，示意我回答正确。
Rabbi Brier tugged on his beard, his eyes narrowing into angry little slits. "And shehakol ," I added. Rabbi Brier triumphantly smacked his desk, signaling that I was correct.
苹果果酱卷淘汰了David Borgen、Yoel Levine和Shlomo Pomerantz。我的朋友Motty Greenberg被起司蛋糕卡住了。我从他脸上的表情就能看出他完全不知道答案。他明智地提供了两个答案，一个针对薄皮，一个针对厚皮，竟然设法留了下来。很难相信这仅仅是第二轮。
Apple strudel took out David [? Borgen ?], Yoel Levine and [? Shlomo ?] Pomerantz. My friend, Motty [? Greenberg ?] got stuck with cheesecake. And I could tell just by the expression on his face that he had absolutely no idea. He wisely offered two answers, one for thin crust and one for thick, and somehow managed to stay alive. It was hard to believe this was only round two.
Avrumi走上前。我对Motty笑了笑。Avrumi可能杀死了他父亲，但他并不聪明，而且他从未在这些事上表现好过。他能进入第二轮就已经很幸运了。
Avrumi stepped forward. I smiled at Motty. Avrumi may have killed his father, but he wasn't very bright. And he never did well at these things. He was lucky to even be in the second round at all.
“贝果，”Brier拉比大喊。贝果？我难以置信地看着Motty。他在开玩笑吗？贝果？
"Bagel," shouted Rabbi Brier. Bagel? I looked at Motty in disbelief. Was he kidding? Bagel?
“贝果，”Avrumi喊道，“Hamotzei。”这完全是扯淡。
"Bagel," called out Avrumi, "Hamotzei." This was bull [BLEEP].
“正确，”Brier拉比喊道，“非常好。”Ephraim Greenblat、Avrumi Epstein和Yoel Frankel全被带有大麦和大块肉的乔伦炖肉（cholent）淘汰了。碎肝配饼干，还有一片生菜和一点橄榄淘汰了另外四个，包括Motty。最后剩下三个。只有Yukisiel Zalman Yehuda Schneck、Avrumi Gruenembaum和我。
"Correct," shouted Rabbi Brier. "Very good." Ephraim Greenblat, Avrumi Epstein, and [? Yoel ?] Frankel all got out on cholent with barley and large pieces of meat. While chopped liver and challah with a slice of lettuce and a bit of olive took out four more, including Motty. And then there were three. It was just Yukisiel Zalman Yehuda Schneck, Avrumi Gruenembaum, and me.
第三轮开始。“Auslander，Shalom，”Brier拉比叫道。我走上前。“冰淇淋，”Brier拉比大喊，“放在甜筒里。”
Round three began. "Auslander, Shalom," called out Rabbi Brier. I stepped forward. "Ice cream," shouted Rabbi Brier, "in a cone."
冰淇淋在甜筒里。冰淇淋在甜筒里。我知道冰淇淋，但他为什么要加上甜筒？放在甜筒里有什么不同吗？冰淇淋甜筒是用什么做的？是蛋糕吗？是威化吗？
Ice cream in a cone. Ice cream in a cone. I knew ice cream, but why would he add the cone? Was there something different if it was in a cone? What was an ice cream cone made of anyway? Was it cake? Was it a wafer?
“冰淇淋在甜筒里，”Brier拉比喊道。冰淇淋是从属于甜筒，还是甜筒从属于冰淇淋？如果是糖筒，也许你真的很渴望甜筒。“冰淇淋在甜筒里，”Brier拉比再次喊道。我别无选择。
"Ice cream in a cone," Rabbi Brier shouted. Is the ice cream subordinate to the cone or is it the cone that's subordinate to the ice cream? If it's a sugar cone, maybe you really desire the cone. "Ice cream in a cone," Rabbi Brier shouted again. I had no choice.
“冰淇淋在甜筒里，”我喊道。“没有祝福。”教室里的每个人都转过头看着我。回顾整个事件，Brier拉比确实没给我留下选择。
"Ice cream in a cone," I called out. "No blessing." Everyone in the classroom turned to face me. Looking back on the whole episode, Rabbi Brier had really left me no choice.
“没有祝福，”Brier拉比说。“为什么没有祝福？”
"No blessing," said Rabbi Brier. "Why no blessing?"
“因为，”我紧张地拉着我的流苏解释道，“因为房间里有臭味（doody）。”房间里陷入了长久的沉默。Motty咯咯笑了起来，其他人也跟着笑。Brier拉比慢慢站起身，粗壮的拳头撑在桌面上。这可能是一个漏洞，但从技术上讲我是对的。Brier拉比自己曾告诉过我们，圣贤说，托拉说，有三种情况绝对禁止 recite祝福。一、面对九岁以上的男性，露出性器官；二、面对三岁以上的女性，露出性器官；三、在粪便存在的情况下。
"Because," I explained, nervously twirling my tzitzis, "Because the room smells like doody." There was a long silence. Motty giggled and others followed. Rabbi Brier slowly rose to his feet, his thick fists pushing themselves into the desktop. It may have been a loophole, but technically speaking I was correct. Rabbi Brier himself had told us that our sages tell us that the Torah tells us that there are three situations in which one is absolutely prohibited from reciting a blessing. One, while facing a male over the age of nine years old whose genitals are showing. Two, while facing a female over the age of three years old whose genitals are showing. And three, in the presence of feces.
坦率地说，考虑到另外两个选择，我想我选了一个最不冒犯的答案。对于一个大块头来说，Brier拉比动起来非常快。
Frankly, given the other two options, I think I chose the least offensive answer. For a big man, Rabbi Brier moved pretty quickly.
“是真的，”在他朝我冲过来时我说，“托拉是这么说的。”他粗暴地抓住我的手臂，把我整个人提起，拖向门口，全程用意第绪语愤怒地咆哮着。“但这有臭味，”我尖叫道，“房间里有臭味。等等。房间里有个裸体女孩。有个裸体女孩。”门在我身后砰地关上了。我站在走廊里，揉着我淤青的手臂。我开始哭泣。祝福竞赛输了。我不是一位伟大的拉比。而我的父亲依然没死。
"It's true," I said as he barreled toward me, "The Torah says that." He grabbed me roughly by my arm, lifting me clear off the ground and dragged me towards the door, shouting angrily in Yiddish the whole time. "But it smells like doody," I yelled. "The room smells like doody. Wait. There's a naked girl in the room. There's a naked girl." The door slammed shut behind me. I stood in the hallway and rubbed my bruised arm. I began to cry. The Blessing Bee was lost. I was not a great rabbi. And my father was still not dead.
我踮着脚尖走向教室门，仔细听着。两分钟后，Yukisiel Zalman Yehuda Schneck败给了枫糖浆无酵饼，最后一个站在台上的男人是Avrumi Gruenembaum。
I tip-toed toward the classroom door and listened closely. Two minutes later, Yukisiel Zalman Yehuda Schneck fell victim to matzoh brei with maple syrup, and the last man standing was Avrumi Gruenembaum.
“苹果，”Brier拉比叫道。
"Apples," called out Rabbi Brier.
“苹果，”Avrumi回答，“Ha-eitz。”
"Apples," Avrumi answered. "Ha-eitz."
“Mazel tov（祝贺），”我们的Brier拉比喊道，“Mazel tov。”完全是扯淡。
"Mazel tov," called our Rabbi Brier. "Mazel tov." Total bull [BLEEP].
那天晚上我们吃了传统的周五晚宴犹太鱼丸——Shehakol，配上一小片胡萝卜——Ho-adamah。父亲又喝醉了，唱着安息日歌曲，胡乱改着词，用拳头用力砸着桌子。妈妈走进厨房端出汤来。当哥哥说他不想喝汤时，父亲打了他，把他推倒在地上，把热腾腾的鸡汤泼在他的脸上。
That night we had the traditional Friday night gefilte fish-- shehakol, with a little slice of carrot-- ho-adamah . My father was drunk again, singing Shabbos songs, fudging the words and banging heavily on the table with his fist. My mother went into the kitchen and brought out the soup. When my brother said he didn't want any, my father slapped him, pushed him over backward onto the floor, and poured the hot chicken soup onto his face.
妈妈把哥哥带进浴室，坐在浴缸边上，用冷毛巾敷着他的脸颊。我回到餐厅，擦掉地上的鸡汤。鸡汤是Shehakol，即使它是和蔬菜一起烹饪的，因为鸡是汤里的主要味道。
My mother took my brother into the bathroom and sat with him on the edge of the bathtub, pressing a cold washcloth against his cheeks. And I went back to the dining room to wipe the chicken soup off the floor. Chicken soup is a shehakol , even if it is cooked with vegetables, since chicken is the dominant taste in the soup.
Brier拉比告诉我们，圣贤说，托拉说，神圣的主给埃及人降下10次灾难是为了教导我们，他给了人们很多忏悔的机会，只有在他们依然继续犯罪的情况下，他才会用死亡来惩罚他们。
Rabbi Brier told us that the sages tell us that the Torah tells us that the Holy One Blessed Be He sent the Egyptians 10 plagues in order to teach us that he gives people many chances to repent, and only then, if they still continue to sin, does he punish them with death.
我下楼走进卧室，没戴小圆帽走了四步路，自慰了，反复开关了灯，然后睡着了。
I went downstairs to my bedroom, took four steps without my yarmulke on, touched myself, flicked the lights off and on and fell asleep.
作家Shalom Auslander。这个故事出自他的回忆录《Foreskin's Lament》。
Writer Shalom Auslander. This story appears in his memoir, Foreskin's Lament.
好吧，我们今天的节目由Lisa Pollak、Jane Feltes和我本人制作，Alex Blumberg、Diane Cook、Wendy Dorr和Sarah Koenig参与制作。我们的资深制作人是Julie Snyder。Seth Lind是我们的制作经理。Adrianne Mathiowetz负责我们的网站。Todd Bachmann、Kevin Clarke、Thea Chaloner和Andy Dixon提供制作协助。
Well, our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak, Jane Feltes and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, and Sarah Koenig. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Kevin Clarke, Thea Chaloner, and Andy Dixon.
特别感谢今天在丹佛采访Marisela和Yadira参加节目开场的记者Helen Thorpe。在我们首次播出这个节目的一年里，她们已经大学毕业并找到了工作，尽管她们在这个国家的合法身份没有改变。
Special thanks today to reporter Helen Thorpe in Denver who interviewed Marisela and Yadira for the opening of today's program. In the year since we first broadcast this show, they have graduated from college and found jobs, though their legal status in this country has not changed.
我们的网站：www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督由Torey Malatia先生负责。管理监督工作的一部分实际上是来参加我们节目的带妆彩排。
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia. Part of the job of management oversight is actually coming to our program's dress rehearsal.
你彩排时的表演——首先，我不明白那些“叭、叭、叭”是什么意思。这是……我不懂那个。
What you did in dress rehearsal-- first of all, I don't get the blah, blah, blahs. Is that-- I'm not getting that.
我是Ira Glass。下周带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
PRI，公共广播国际。国际
PRI, Public Radio International. international